bonjour françois bayrou bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur notre radio maire de pau
président du modem comment avez vous
réagi à cette annonce finale et surprise
d'une augmentation de nos autoroutes et
leurs tarifs cette affaire de
privatisation d une concession
autoroutière puisque c'est ça le nom
exact
cette privatisation et depuis dix ans le
symbole exact le plus significatif d'une
certaine opacité française de la manière
dont les affaires se traitent sans que
les citoyens en soit informé et même
contre leurs sentiments et des avantages
perpétuelle qu'on consent qu'on
multiplie à l'égard d'un certain nombre
de groupes privés décision prise en 2005
par dominique de villepin est déjà à
l'époque vous étiez contre un je dois je
suis allé au conseil d'état tout seul
comme citoyen pour m'opposer à cette
décision
reprenant les affaires en trois phrases
un début de l'été les chantiers quand
même qu'ils doivent démarrer a lieu dans
les pyrénées-orientales c'est la 9 entre
le boulou à la frontière espagnole
devrait y être pour nom nombre des
pyrénées-orientales c'est pas des
pyrénées atlantiques j'entends bien mais
c'est quand même pas loin de chez vous
grâce à shawi cet important mais
revenons au point les autoroutes étaient
entièrement financée et leur
amortissement s'achevait
dans ces années 2005 2006 et donc on
savait qu'elle allait dégager les
bénéfices très important ses bénéfices
avaient été prévus pour financer ces
jean pierre raffarin qui avait décidé
cela pour financer des grands travaux
autoroutiers et ferroviaires
on avait gage et les grands travaux
autoroutiers et ferroviaires sur les
bénéfices des autoroutes on a décidé de
privatiser tout cela par une décision
que le parlement n'a pas examiné c'est
pour ça je suis allé au
conseil d'état
qui a été prise en catimini comme tout
se fait en france et depuis tout
l'effort des sociétés autoroutières et
de faire prolonger cette privatisation
elle été prise pour 30 ans on en est
maintenant à 34 ou 35 ans et bien c'est
purement et simplement
inacceptable françois bayrou le ministre
des transports explique que c'est le
seul moyen d'aller plus vite de prendre
en charge rapidement ces travaux qui
sont par ailleurs nécessaire parce qu'il
nous dit sinon il nous faut un accord de
bruxelles un vote du parlement et ça
prendrait au minimum un an est ce que
vous estimez que ces travaux sont
nécessaires et à ce moment là faut quand
même bien les financer je pense que tout
cela c'est de l'intérêt en plus ça va
créer l'emploi tout cela c'est de
l'intox les je rappelle que les sociétés
autoroutières dans la plupart des cas
font faire ces travaux par leurs
filiales ou des filiales voisine donc
d'une certaine manière l'investissement
revient à ceux qui ont ces bénéfices
très important mais le pire dans tout ça
c'est que le gouvernement refuse de
transmettre l'accord qui permet aux
sociétés autoroutières de faire ça les
citoyens peuvent pas en avoir
connaissance monsieur avrillé
qui est un ancien adjoint à grenoble est
allé demander est allé au ministère a
écrit pour demander cet accord et puis
ensuite il a écrit à la commission de
transmission des documents
administratifs il a obtenu un jugement
qui oblige l'état donné cet accord et
hier on a appris que l'état allait en
cassation pour refuser aux citoyens de
savoir ce qu'il ya dans cet accord quoi
vous pensez qu'à des choses à cacher si
ces 106 et votre avis dit je pense qui
sait que si le gouvernement s'oppose à
la transmission de la corse est
probablement qui a des dispositions dans
cet accord que les citoyens
n'accepterait pas il ya quelque chose
vous vous souvenez il ya à peine
quelques mois le gouvernement a dit
c'est scandaleux cette affaire des
autoroutes on a même
prononcez le mot de renationalisation à
quoi j'ai jamais cru parce que ça
coûterait des dizaines de milliards les
contrats sont extrêmement fouillé
travail et sécurisé donc donc on ne
reviendra pas en arrière donc le
gouvernement à vis à envisager la
renationalisation aujourd'hui ils
allongent en catimini la concession et
il augmente les tarifs autoroutiers et
donc vous voyez bien qu'il ya dans tout
cela quelque chose qui est une
spoliation
de ce que devrait être le bien de tous
les citoyens parce que tout cela c'est
les français qui l'ont payé qu'ils ont
payé comme contribuables qu'ils ont payé
comme usagers et c'est tellement le
symbole de tout ce qui en france est
opaque
dissimulé
connivent
entre entre les la puissance publique et
des grandes entités privées que ça
mérite qu'on se batte et que sur une
antenne comme la vôtre en effet en le
défendant pour vous suggérer à la limite
qui est des actes de corruption dans ce
que vous êtes en train de nous dire
j'aurais non je pense justement on
aimerait juste qu'on soit bien en accord
avec vos arguments c'est et moi j'essaie
de prononcer des mots exacts je n'ai
aucun élément sur ces choses là sur la
corruption
le gmail ile de france à alger une
certitude c'est qu'il y a des relations
entre la puissance publique et ses
grandes entités privées qui ne sont pas
saines il ya quelque chose qui fait que
les citoyens en france sont considérés
comme étant de deuxième zone que c'est
le pouvoir dans l'ombre des couloirs et
des cabinets avec des
personnalités qui passe du pouvoir à la
puissance se priver qui sont embauchés
par s'y connaissent ils ont des carnets
d'adressés où ça et pour moi
pénalisant pour le développement de la
france à si vous le voulez bien vous emm
en écouter un auditeur
bonjour yves
bonjour if vous nous appelez d'annecy
dans le département de haute-savoie bien
entendu on vous écoute comme toujours
que voulez vous nous dire sur ce thème
des des autoroutes et de l'augmentation
qui a finalement été décidé alors la
maaf l'iran fait d'eux de réflexion la
première fait je pense qu'en france on a
quand même un réseau autoroutier qui est
en excellente état et qui est aussi
extrêmement vaste
si on veut de l'améliorer certainement
que c'est une c'est une bonne idée mais
cependant on peut constater depuis une
bonne dizaine d'années une dégradation
majeure du réseau secondaire et je
m'étonne que l'on trouve des moyens de
financements pour les autoroutes alors
qu'on n'arrive pas à en trouver
peut-être fois qu'il est ponctionnée sur
les péages d'autoroute pour aller
financer le reste qui se dégrade je suis
pas contre eux payer encore plus pour
des choses qui soient utiles nous sommes
juste d'accord pour trouver globalement
nos autoroutes bien entretenu et pour
trouver des routes secondaires vont de
moins en moins bien est ce que vous
faites le constat c'est exactement ce
qui était prévu par la décision
des premières années de
2002 3 4 c'est exactement ce qui était
prévu ce qui était prévu c'est ce que ce
monsieur dit les bénéfices des sociétés
autoroutières vont être réinvestis dans
d'autres voies routières ou dans des
voies ferroviaires ou dans d'autres
autoroutes on enfin on avait le bénéfice
de l'investissement considérable qui a
été voulu par les français consomment et
on s'en servait pour équiper le pays ici
on se trouve je crois que la cour des
comptes qui a fait un rapport
extrêmement sévère sur cette affaire a
dit que c'était comme si on avait
emprunté à près de 8% alors que l'argent
est aujourd'hui à 1 % s'il vous plaît un
oui ou un non et je vous remercie d'être
venu finalement témoigner de votre avis
et julien même de vos questions en tout
cas sur ce qui se passe ce matin sur rtl
une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
ne serait-elle pas une bonne idée elle
serait une bonne idée mais vous voyez
bien que tout ça a été le fait des
gouvernements successifs d'un bord et de
l'autre
et que donc c'est au fond donc vous
pensez que personne n'y a intérêt au
forum se tient tout le monde se tient
parce que tout le monde a pris sa part
de cette décision que je considère moins
comme allant à l'encontre de l'intérêt
national merci beaucoup françois vrod
est revenue ce matin sur rtl